what's up everybody it's morning the
Black Widow trailer dropped six hours
earlier than was expected I went to bed
at a decent time to try to wake up with
a decent time and it dropped six hours
earlier so just now watching it for the
first time let's do this together
first trailer of phase four
I found nothing
[Music]
I got this job this family
but nothing lasts forever it's just like
the leaks said it started out what
that's crazy it was true or gentle even
hurry
it's never easy these days
so what are you going to do I've lived a
lot of lives done from my past
and now you're out there I know you know
I'm out here so we gonna talk like
grown-ups is that what they are
oh it's good to see you
unfinished business
we have to go back to where it all
started
lucky us
one thing's for sure
it's gonna be a hell of a reunion
[Music]
thank God still fits back together again
you wanna fit
[Music]
Wow
that was actually insanely good that
that was really good it's what I
expected from a black widow movie action
the hand hand comment that was like
extremely the crazy thing about this is
I did a video I don't know a week or so
ago that was talking about the leaked
description for the trailer and it was
100% right it seems like it starts off
with the vengers in-game dialogue shows
videos from the past movies from Black
Widow from age of Ultron that showed
Nick Fury now it did say the voice
couldn't differentiate between Nick Fury
offended by Ross that was clearly
federal Ross they de-aged him let me
take a look at this in that one scene it
was actually kind of weird it kind of
threw me off they D aged him a lot yeah
that's crazy he's very young now I know
it's obviously said back in the past
it's set between Civil War and Avengers
infinity war but that's I mean we saw
him during that time so it's weird that
they D aged him that much that's kind of
crazy but perhaps a thunderbolt set up
coming along the way it's weird that
she's already dead because it just makes
you wonder how you're gonna feel about
the movie but this trailer was super
awesome let me know what you thought
about this trailer I'm going to do a
complete breakdown of the trailer right
now of course so it's exciting phase 4
has officially begun let me know your
thoughts down below and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof